all right in this video we are going to
talk about the sources tab so I'm going
to command option I which is my favorite
way to open up dev tools and it's
already on sources here so the sources
tab it is pretty interesting it from the
sound of it it's where you go to look at
each of the sources you can look at each
of the public documents that the page
has loaded and that's true but when
you're going to use it is when you're
really trying to debug something the
bigger your program gets the harder it
is to find what's broken if something
stops working that can be a huge time
sucker but the sources tab is an awesome
tool for helping with just that so what
we're gonna do here is we can set
something called breakpoints looks like
there's already some set up I was
messing around on here a little bit
earlier so I'll say I want line 18 I
just clicked it over here and now it's
over here when i refresh the page it's
going to stop at each of these places it
says it's paused and when that happens I
can go to any of these other tabs and
see exactly what's going on that's a big
deal because it allows you to really go
step by step in your code and look at
the big picture at a very specific
moment in your codes run you can set
your breakpoints based on a JavaScript
event excuse me based on a specific line
of code based on something to do with
the DOM and manipulating that which
we'll get to in other videos it is a
really versatile tool and what I want
you to remember about the sources tab is
it is really helpful in debugging your
code